hey what is that what is good come on in
what a powder us up it's the band
mailbag and they should know who you are
yes this is our Savior makeup specialist
our face saver she's checking herself
out are you okay you look great right
now
powder enough guys we are recording this
the week before so happy Monday to
everybody we are on vacation right now
but we wanted to give you something for
the week unfortunately it's only gonna
be one episode this week
give us a break we're going on vacation
but then again as I said on last
Wednesday's show when we get back in
this room if you watch us on YouTube
it's gonna look completely different
it's gonna be wood all over the place of
cool pictures I'm excited Sims are you
excited I am excited yes I actually just
thank you for applying some extra powder
of woody I was actually just reminiscing
about how you didn't want bathing suit
at my parents house again I just it's
one of those white things he did not
tell me until I was leaving that he had
new bathing Zubaz I know but it's also
just it's one of those weird things I
also think about like I know nobody
wants to put their balls where another
man's balls well that's weird but like
we do so much grosser things in our
lives
what's grosser than like I said I've
seen you like pick your nose and like
rub your eyes just like 25 minutes ago
and then you have shook 80 other
people's hands you also pick their nose
and that's on your hand and now in your
nose and in your eye but that was okay
meanwhile the clean the clean well it's
the weirdest thing like if you really
think about it people pool yeah yeah and
your but the funniest thing was I sent
you that meme the next day yes that was
guy guy is confused why other people
won't wear his bathing suits from his
drawer it's just you know it's the fear
that I'm gonna take them off and I'm
gonna look down and go that's a phil
simms hanging on to my leg right there
yeah yeah so here's what happened Josh
isn't here he's going to speak to
Maryland kids because josh is the future
of the country
Josh afree ran for president I believe
he's become that big-time but he gave me
all these questions there's a bunch of
questions here so we're gonna see how
many was there
even know he's big-time I don't even get
it I mean I don't even know its title
and I see him every day what does he do
I don't know how did they know how did
he sell himself to the Turks that they
thought we should have him in for a
guest speaker I don't know I mean kids
got good media good PR good marketing
yeah yeah yeah right Nick said anis
because he says goodie good evening he's
very professional
guys if we don't get to your question
I'm sorry we we're not used to this
we're not used to going hey can we get
questions and like 400 come in like I
have so many DMS I have to go through so
what I'm gonna do the ones that we don't
get to there is a new feature on
Instagram where you type in a question
and then I can answer it with video I'm
gonna do that I'll do some next week too
before I go on vacation I'm not leaving
right away
I'll do it some of the yeah someone like
Monday or Tuesday where you guys on the
simpson Lefko Instagram I'll get on
Instagram stories I'll answer as many
questions as I can
we love entered and engaging with you
guys we love the reddit we love the
Twitter we love the Instagram you guys
are great you're really the only reason
we're able to do this yeah that's right
thank you so much let's get to the
questions first one up this one comes
from Cameron Johnson
cam two M's 35 Johnson who is the one
NFL player you would trade lives with
for one day oh so pull up the teams
yeah but also you can think of it a few
ways I know whose body do you want to
have something whose life do you want to
have do you want to be single and young
do you want to be like focused and rich
be only get it for one day no because
it's it's weird because I run away I
think of Brady and Rogers because I mean
they they have the life that I wanted
right so that you cannot trade bodies I
know
it's trade lies right which but so I do
think of this my first thought was I
want to have se Kwang's body and just be
like won a race right every but his
life's not cool enough yet that much
money yes
so I you know lives with changing I mean
Odell is also towards the top of the
high I'm gonna go with von Miller
and the reason is is I follow him on a
lot of social the man is always in a
private jet the man is doing things like
shark fishing and then he's going out
and he's clubbing and he's getting a new
tat on his hamstring he's got that fat
check
he's got the notoriety he's got a
recognizable face so people will know
that I'm famous and he's in Denver yeah
so things are illegal there yes yeah
that's a good one
Thanks I know that's why I tend to want
to think of like a it to me I guess at
the end of the day it's gonna come down
to between Grunk Oh Oh me Jay like Grunk
you have a free pass that be whoever you
want everybody that's the first week Ron
kotoba I'll go back right they could
both go to a club right and do the worm
Grunk is gonna go this guy knows how to
party gel they're gonna go you're gonna
risk injury oh why don't you get back in
front you better move than the worm so
okay so from that simple and then I did
think of Khalil Mac because of Coyle Mac
well because of like what you said like
his body like I also been thinking that
like I would love to feel like let me
feel what it's like to be 256 pounds
doesn't say true body still that's where
my mind goes to the body nonetheless I
mean wouldn't you like to be like feel
how Odell Beckham jr. runs a forty-year
he's the first time in my life that I
would like to go to the gym I'd be like
this is gonna be great yeah but let's
get this out of the way because I'd like
to do other stuff okay no I'm a get out
the way like let's get the gym out of
the way cuz now I get to go do things
I'm going on Beckham jr. all right good
job cam Johnson next one up
J underscore o or s ik underscore Justin
what do you think about girlies comments
on a future hold out for guaranteed
contracts so if I remember right he said
that the players have to be willing to
hold out to get future guaranteed
contracts yes we have always said this
if you want to get paid they need to be
willing to sit out yeah and they're
gonna have to make it really hurt the
NFL owners right we've always said that
it's really gonna hurt the bottom 15-20
percent of the league really I mean it's
more than that really it's probably 50
to 60 not more than that why do 70 days
and that's why the NBA it's like they
got these scrubs making 15 they don't
even care right I think that the few
things are very interesting one the XFL
is starting the same year as the
possible holdout yes to Spurrier made a
comment last week or this week in actual
time where he said if Shakima Griffin
gets cut will sign them right away
there's gonna be two leagues that are
gonna be willing to pay these guys I
think the NFL if there's other options
for these guys to go to could really
hurt the NFL in the long run especially
the low-level guys like you're saying
cuz they're gonna be those other leagues
am you willing to pay those yes that's
right like that guy that's you know a
third-year player who's still you know
but let's just say a fifth year player
who's a good player that's making like
the league minimum you go there's a lot
of teams of a like hiss and he's got a
good name he just didn't hit that that
big-time contract here or whatever it
may be
yeah those are the guys I would say that
the XFL and some of the other leagues
are gonna be able to steal and go we'll
listen we'll value as a little bit more
of a star league give you more face time
so you'll get some more endorsements
that I would think they're gonna improv
promise some of that as well as part of
the package like like David Beckham when
he came over to the LA Galaxy like the
contract wasn't really the contract they
also promised them all these off the
fields work but I would think that's a
concern guaranteed contracts will love
to see them happen certainly how much
waves do you think Kirk Cousins getting
that one is gonna have well I think it's
put it on everybody's at least a
forefront of their brain now
thing that I think players are gonna
have to realize which it really won't
matter but it's just the optics aren't
going to look good right what's like we
talked are always painted to be very
selfish yes so they're gonna be look
selfish [ __ ] those people don't let them
get in your head also the numbers of the
contracts aren't gonna look as good no
you know if it's Karen Dean and get into
what we do those are the numbers you're
gonna they're gonna get like the
two-year 36 million and for a
quarterback yes you're not gonna get von
miller six years 101 million you're
gonna get von miller three years fifty
million guaranteed and then really okay
there's some more risk there but not
really at the end of the day because
most teams are gonna let you go before
you get to year four or five and ii FL
we'll we'll start doing shorter
contracts no no I don't think so either
that's their secret bargaining chip all
these years six seven year deals Mike
Rogers and Julio Jones are in the
position they're in right now because
they were the good guys and did that for
their team good question or Resik I will
say this too I thought about it I don't
know if this is gonna change by Monday
so if it is I apologize for dating it I
am hoping that Le'Veon Bell changes it
no I I'm hoping that he goes through
this franchise tag and I hope he plays
with him and the reason is he could be
in the same situation that Kirk Cousins
was there I think the goal is if you get
franchise tag once I'm holding out that
second time I'm gonna play you know why
because look what I'm with Kirk Cousins
is the amount of power he had because if
levy on bail comes back for the third
year and I know it's harder because god
forbid anything happens you can have the
Steelers by the balls or you can hit the
open market in your prime so I'm hoping
that it I'm kind of changed my mind is
prime though I know that's the problem
you know again quarterbacks
NFL franchise quarterback let's I mean
for the most part it's like a 10-year
career right
they're running back it's a different
thing and I know that's what's screwed
up is they're gonna use that against
them I know I just that you're leveraged
they're gonna go well you're kind of
past your prime you've taken a lot of
hits and you've run the ball and catch
the ball and you know so that's gonna
luckily he's 26 that's right because
that's the thing about the
cousins too in that age range if you can
become a true free agent at 27 you can't
bring me that 30-year [ __ ] no it's over
no all right next 127
how do Patrick mahomes and Josh Allen's
arm strength compared to Matt Stafford
I remember seeing a lot of comments from
people saying you didn't bring up Matt
Stafford and strongest arms yeah so
mahomes and Josh Allen amassed effort by
the way little nugget Josh Allen's
Madden arm strength 99 right yeah Josh
Allen's arm is as strong as I've ever
seen that's not saying so how would you
rank those three guys
all right so hmm mahomes Allen Stafford
I think my Holmes and Allen probably and
like everybody here this okay Matthew
Stafford is one of the greatest arms in
the history of the sport and I mean that
from all things thrower not just
strongest like he can do every throw
from every angle every platform doesn't
matter where his feet are so and we
would just pure strength Adam left go I
think Josh Allen and Patrick mahomes
have a hair stronger arm I don't think
there is a gift of the throw and when I
say a hair stronger arm I'm talking like
if we went baseball terms we're like
mahomes and Josh Allen are throwing 103
and 102 and staffers throwing 101 like
it's not that far off like it's okay but
I do think that Stafford I'm gonna still
say he's a more gifted all-around
thrower than both of them at this point
mahomes has a chance to be very much
like that sidearm 40-yard out route sir
I'm in the I'm in the pockets escaping
and there's you know there's a Golden
Tate up on the right side lines
involving the corner safety right and he
can just throw it five feet off the
ground and still get it they're very
special that way so I would say their
arms are stronger but Stafford's arms
one of the greatest of all time
how about this you had in rankings yeah
Josh Allen throwing power 99 Matt
Stafford 98 Patrick mahomes 1997 okay
are the other guys that are 97 Cam
Newton right Aaron Rodgers Joe Flacco
okay I don't know if lat goes there
anymore Flacco's arm is radius 90
six yeah so I don't know why Aaron
Rodgers wouldn't be the 99 I don't know
that I think Aaron Rodgers is so good at
other things that I feel like they give
bigger throwing power to people that
that's their main that little thing
right yeah all right now next one J
Sully
Jeremy Sullivan underscore twenty four
is it going Sully what is your favorite
Aaron Rodgers moment there's a few to
choose from he's got a Hail Mary against
the line she's got a Hail Mary against
the Cardinals
that was really back-to-back Hail Mary's
against the Cardinals yeah he's got the
throw against Dallas on the run that
came to my head I mean the moment of
that game that was third and twenty
third and 2000 against the number one
seed cowboy exactly right
all you the whole time flushed out of
the pocket running to his lap rolling to
his left throwing across the body forty
yards in the air on a rope on the
outside number which where the guy could
actually fall out of bounds and it hit
him in two Jared cook their chest still
amazing catch by Jericho it was yes I
really love the play that got called
back against the Chicago Bears when he
stepped up in the pocket rolled away and
then jumped and then got hit by two
people in the air and still was able to
throw the ball 50 yards for a touchdown
Davante Adams and get called back that's
one of my favorites or that there's the
jump pass and week one against the
Jacksonville Jaguars two years ago
everyone is jumping and he threw a
30-yard touchdown passes he had someone
tackling him as he was throwing is the
thing that people don't appreciate on
Aaron Rodgers is the strength he gets
with neither feet on the ground right
which if you've ever tried to jump and
throw a pass you have no strength it's
all your upper body exactly it's all its
core and it's as deflection as I had
some throws in the Superbowl that were
just out of balance the Super Bowl is
one of the greatest performances ever
that kind of goes on it I guess the
throw to Randall Cobb against the
Chicago Bears so you just caught the
defense completely napping
I guess it's got to be the Detroit one
that Detroit Hail Mary
troit Hail Marys at the highest vote of
deep [ __ ] as a football team we were all
sitting there like damn this is the
only guy we think in football that might
be able to get this Hail Mary they're
from their own 40 and he sat there
baited everybody in ran to his right
right and then threw a ball that really
I don't think anybody on the planet
could throw the ball that high and that
far at the same time hmm so that would
be though that would be the first one
the other one is of course the Arizona
game where he threw to him Aires on the
same drive to win the [ __ ] that was send
the game at over one to Jeff Janis and
then Richard Rodgers again another
underrated game when Atlanta was the
they had their Atlanta Superbowl run and
he beat Atlanta by himself in the
Georgia Dome in the divisional game
right yeah they lost that game no I
meant the regular season one he won
though I think oh well did he okay when
he ran for like a hundred yards and
threw for 300 I got to find this well
there was the divisional game the year
they went to the Super Bowl where he
went into Atlanta Atlanta was the number
one seed and he tore them apart they
might have but then the next week they
beat Chicago in Chicago Jay Keller hurt
his ACL and they went on to win the
Super Bowl with again his stats I want
to say it was like 22 or 28 or something
like that but the throws and the quality
of throws he made in that game he was
the only guy in the sport at that time
that I think could have made those type
of throws to him I could talk about that
[ __ ] often I mean it's hard to
come up with the just what was all of
Fame highlight reels gonna be that's
really amazing next up Tyler
Irwin T man 6 7 9 6
I was wondering for Simms if in a locker
room after a guy gets suspended by their
peds for or say for what Jameis did if
guys act different around them or if the
locker room just moves on yeah have you
had any players that had off the field
because I asked you Monday or last
Monday if the peds thing ever happened
never happened now but guys being
suspended I think a good question for
you would be kind of Keyshawn Johnson
yeah what's going on all that off the
field stuff arguing with the team and
like that well he didn't get the benefit
of the doubt because he wasn't
necessarily everybody's favorite
teammate and things like that things
move on though it's the NFL you don't
have time to sit there and reminisce now
when you do things like
Jameis Winston or you get suspended or
things like that you definitely are
gonna lose a little respect to the
locker room they're not gonna say it to
your face but you know guys are yeah
they're just gonna look at that guy as
being not dependable they're gonna speak
under the breath of their closest
teammates about how he's a cheater or
he's a douchebag or whatever it is so
that's what you lose but no the locker
room is not gonna reflect on it long I
mean in fact a lot of the time the
coaches they do their best to to like
well the year Keshawn loss we have this
guy Charles Lee who had a little
potential and talent and he was going to
take over and Gruden was like Charles
Lee he's gonna be the guy and he's sure
videos and hype up so the team could get
behind him so we could just get off of
it and gonna hey we're gonna be okay
this guy can run those same routes
Keyshawn did and we can do some things
what I learned that all or nothing is
that they pound a message into your guys
heads because you really just have
meeting after meeting after meeting so
you meet with your position group then
you meet with your coordinator then you
all meet with special teams and you meet
with the coach and the messaging has to
be consistent throughout yes and so if
you're a wide receiver like Keyshawn or
or whatever you're gonna hear from your
wide receivers coach then you're gonna
do the offensive coordinator meeting and
he's gonna say Charles Lee's gonna step
it up then your head coaches me like
Charles Lee's gonna step it up then
specialties like everybody stepping up
by the way Charles Lee's girls tie it up
right and by the end of the week you're
going I mean Charles Lee might be a
hall-of-famer right yeah the defense is
they're pulling for them they're telling
them things during the week so in terms
of losing respect for a guy it does
happen
is there ever a guy have you ever been
around another guy calling out another
guy for some [ __ ] in a locker room like
it's just tested the patience of
everybody so much yeah let me just think
of some of the Tennessee Titan teams I
was on it was nothing like that
you know like III did again I thought of
the Keyshawn thing a little bit there
you around any weird Albert Haynesworth
stuff no Albert was on the straight and
narrow at that time because he was close
to breaking the bank and he wasn't gonna
screw it up right he's saying all the
right things yes he did no I can't say
that I was around anything like that I'm
just trying to think if there's any
other instances
of guys getting suspended but you know
it's weird I just was never on any teams
or guys got suspended mmm a whole lot
anyone ever step to Tebow like okay
Vince had some issues when I was in
tennis yeah right yeah and it's a weird
dynamic because everybody recognizes the
talent Vince had everybody recognizes
that Vince had a great heart but also
everybody I don't want to say there was
a there was a lack of respect because
they didn't know how mature Vince was
and handling the job right we're really
caring about football right where I
don't want to say it was like a total
blatant disrespect but I just mean we're
guys question that like can he can he be
our guy can he'd be the professional he
needs to be to be the quarterback of our
football team for five more years
anyone ever step to him we go it's time
to grow up did you ever see anything
like that
no no and in fact with him no it was it
was a lot of a lot by the time I feel
like somebody says that it's already too
late he's out of the league so what
happens with those guys too much of the
time is everyone ends up babysitting
them too much and never really keeps it
real with them and by the time they
finally get real with themselves it's
over this is from BAM FinCEN just listen
to the 4th of July episode how can you
not have Jimmy G in the convo for top 5
legs and ass dude is built like a brick
[ __ ] hashtag legs and ass well but
top 5 at what quarter rock top 5
quarterback legs and ass and we put him
close to it right I think I talked about
him but I didn't put him in the other it
wasn't there with Russell Wilson Cam
Newton dak Prescott Carson Wentz I think
Drew Brees is in there yeah maybe I
could have gone Garoppolo over drew a
pretty good legs and ass he does and
yeah I don't know I don't think you know
Derek Carr is another guy it's sneaky
you mentioned there are cars legs and
assert their insight about Kyle and
Jimmy G's relationship how are they
they're great I mean I think Jimmy G did
everything they wanted to in the
offseason and I think the thing that I
took away from it more than anything and
I know Kyle compliment comp commented
about this publicly but even from my
conversations with oh yeah you know I
think he was glad to see Jimmy G go
through a few struggling points and
practice and things like that he's
getting to know
not only the player but the person too
and that's a huge part you know how can
he handle criticism how is he gonna
handle my criticism when I tell him
practice was shitty or how's he gonna
handle everybody look at that on my game
well you're the highest paid quarterback
of football and you just threw four
interceptions and oti right whatever it
is how did he take those are the things
that I think excited I own yes well I
was gonna say if you were on the
Patriots you're used to getting [ __ ] oh
you are right that's exactly I would say
if you're coming for the Patriots you're
gonna be able to handle criticism really
well because I know a guy at the local
high school that dot d'Anjou 42 what
player would you want to be with during
the zombie apocalypse
Fletcher Cox so I am I know that Malcolm
Jenkins actually has a fallout shelter
in his house in Philadelphia just for
the zombie apocalypse he took me in
there he has duct tape and lanterns and
knives and guns and all this stuff and I
said so this is where you'd come from
the zombie apocalypse and he goes no he
goes do you know what you're supposed to
do during a zombie apocalypse I said
wait you know what to do during a zombie
apocalypse he goes yes I'm gonna come
here I'm gonna get all of my materials
I'm going to high ground I go wait so
you've already planned out he goes yes
takes me to his living room shows me the
books at the top of his bookcase and
it's like five books about how to
survive a zombie apocalypse he thinks
one is going to happen why the high
ground it's just like uni like knows
like areas that he's gonna go to basic
war tactics yeah more tact to change
strategy Amba scam run they can only
walk I never know like my thing is if
zombies can walk I'm fighting if zombies
can run you're screwed I'm gonna kill
myself
they're gonna kill me because I don't
think there's anything scarier than like
damn zombies in that Will Smith movie
yeah yeah like I'm gonna die I'm taking
Fletcher Cox or tear a little wanna
restate that for the record
tale a little one or Fletcher Cox see
that's the thing is I would take LaJuan
over
Fletcher Cox because Fletcher Cox is
gonna like I'm gonna kill them all and
the ones can look me and be like run I
have you
he's like Hodor which I know you don't
know is the game of Game of Thrones but
he is natural instinct is to protect a
person yeah but your Cox natural
instinct is to decimate other people
right so yeah I went a little bit of a
protector obviously you want a little
Juan is out here going with with Tyrone
Smith I'm going with the biggest person
I've ever seen in my life yeah okay how
great was drew brees during his prime
with the Saints 2009 to 2013 was it more
Sean Payton or was drew a top
quarterback in the league and that is
from Eric Wilkerson Thank You Aaron a
good question Eric Wilkerson um no he's
certainly um he was certainly one of the
top quarterbacks in the league at that
time there's no doubt about it again
drew Brees I know people think I'm a
little critical of him which III know I
am I think it's just your love for Sean
Payton's my love for Sean Penn during
that run let me just tell everybody drew
Brees from 2009 to 2013 threw for forty
three hundred yards forty six hundred
yards 54 hundred yards 50 100 yards 50
100 yards and his is touchdowns
respectively were 34 33 46 43 39 yes you
need two years of quarterback ratings
three years with quarterback ratings
over a hundred yes one at 110 yeah what
was that was that two thousand nine
thousand eleven eleven 71 percent
completion percentage a hundred and ten
quarterback rating forty six touchdowns
to 14 interceptions with fifty four
hundred yards yeah that's pretty
impressive
III think I think this I don't I don't
think I can say with Drew Brees there's
ever one season where I say he was the
best quarterback in football like even
the year you're talking about in 2011
where he had that great year there was
another guy with a hundred and twenty
two rating and his name was Aaron
Rodgers and he threw one lesson and ate
less interceptions so wow those are the
things where I think he's been
victimized by some other great
quarterbacks who have had great years
during his greatest years but I don't
think I could ever look at one year of
Drew Brees and ever say he was the
greatest quarterback in footballer ever
years where he wasn't in the top
five ah because I think that's part of
Drew Brees is greatness maybe not dying
yes yeah I think when you really look at
all of his years yeah he's never really
had a bad year no he's no no he has
always been in the top ten every year
yes which I but again see that's where I
look at Sean Payton his greatness
touchdowns last year yeah they ran the
hell out of that ball last year twenty
three touchdowns eight interceptions for
Drew Brees twenty three is the lowest
amount of touchdowns he threw in his
entire career since 2003 when he had 11
when I think he got injured right and
then the next Wow no I don't think he
got injured but 11 since 2003 it's been
15 years since he's thrown that little
touchdown so that's interesting yeah
well and they were a better football
team too they're more well-rounded their
defense was rested because they can run
the ball and do things like that so it's
a more it's a better way to play
football
I think we're again five five thousand
yard seasons it's unbelievable all of
that again though I do think the system
is tremendous I don't think he's ever
been the greatest quarterback in the
sport at any single one year he's been
in that conversation for top three top
five a bunch of times but I would also
look at you know again we always put
wins and losses with all other
quarterbacks Drew Brees for some reason
does not seem to get that on him that's
one thing I always push back against
when other quarterbacks lose it's their
fault but when New Orleans Saints lose
it's not really ever drew Brees at all
that's why I push basak again against
the notion at times mmm and he hasn't
exactly set the world on fire in playoff
football either so I think that's where
I look at it and go yeah that's why I
don't put him at the greatest of all
time just because of some of those
things like when I look at playoff
football yeah you know why he hasn't
taken off in playoff football because
those defenses took take away some of
those easy completions he got all
regular-season some of the great Sean
Payton creative screens and short passes
pretty good in college in postseason
football yeah they're never gonna be bad
but like he went up to your Philadelphia
game right when they played you guys a
few years ago he they won the game do
you remember that year he had like two
pickups Nick he was so he was not good
at all I mean not good at all they had
to stop throwing the ball because you
couldn't trust him he threw one wobbler
after another you know they go to
Seattle the week after that
that game so again I know it sounds like
I'm actually talking negatively about
them but I don't I can't ever sit here
and say drew brees is the best at this I
mean I could say he's the most accurate
sure that's about one thing I will say
about him by the way he can converse a
12 consecutive seasons of 4,000 yards
which is pretty damn impressive the one
thing I will say is when I watch the man
work mm-hmm I don't know if somebody
leads a team better than Drew no he's
all-in he lives it I respect all that
that's why again I don't want this to be
a crap on him think this is where I hate
like you're not allowed to give your
real assessments of know your thing is
he's already at seventy thousand career
passing yards and he's gonna people are
gonna say he's a top five guy all time
and you're going he can't do a lot of
things the other guys can do no he
cannot all right this is a bonus Derrick
dot ran can big [ __ ] be added
full-time and rename the podcast Sims
and Sons make it happen BR well that
sucks for you yeah what the [ __ ] it
should be left go in the sims's sims is
in left co now he's under contract with
CBS still yeah he's still collecting CBS
Joe's got one more year I think of uh
you know pregame right so we'll see
where it goes from there I do think data
is interest in radio whoa so I could see
him doing that when all said and done
first of all and if we have an extra
podcast certainly he loves coming on he
does I know and I think he's having a
whole new generation of people that have
been coming up to him lately like saying
the things we say don't I get that are
like hey that was enjoying it by the way
big Phil's the man yeah I'm like yeah
yes yeah and now that he respects my
athletic prowess yes never know yeah you
never know
all right this one is from at to
underscore one underscore oh I love
y'all show full disclosure I hated Chris
Simms ever since they benched major
Applewhite for him but now I've turned
the corner on him y'all are great my
question is did Simms actually beat out
major or was it a phone call from the
big [ __ ] I've been wondering this
forever keep it goin fellas out like I
have a feeling that you're insulted at
the question I am insulted at the
question like my dad has gone to like
three of my games in the history of my
life so does he do you think he'd be the
kind of guy that Phil wasn't like a
helicopter dad at all like he acted like
Chris wasn't even this son no I mean he
went to only two of my high school games
my whole life so to say that it is
insulting major Applewhite's dad was the
dad that would call and go please play
major heed dear screwing him even though
he doesn't have any talent and so you
were the number one rated quarterback
coming out of high school you're the
number one player coming out of high
school yes like Texas got you and they
had a parade my issue with the whole
major conversation the people that
backed major is I want to go then you
didn't back Texas I'm just sorry because
first of all you would never just divide
over a quarterback do you love Texas or
not right so you would root for Texas no
matter what not only route from one
major was in and then Chris's and I
don't like them somehow win but don't
let Chris be good then you're not a true
Texas fan and then you're also
neglecting the guy that put his whole
life into Texas football like whole life
and then you're accepting the guy who
had the highest body fat percentage on
the football team who was never around
the guys and never worked very hard so
you're saying you gave your whole life
you mean you that's all I did
that's all I did and that's every and
major would talk about it you know all
the guys on the team follow you and how
you know you're such a great leader and
all that yeah because I lived it and you
weren't around the team major we never
saw you so that pisses me was your body
fat in Texas like nine and what was his
27 something and it pisses me off it's
the same thing that goes survive around
the subject about Mack Brown [ __ ] that
conversation too I'm sick of it what
conversations you kind of like backstab
Mack no my love is to the University of
Texas and I was asked if Mack Brown
should keep his job and I said no I
think the time has come to part
around the year that he ended up being
subsequently fired that year the year
they sucked for the second or third year
in a row and send nobody to the NFL for
the first time in like 90 years in the
draft and you love Mack as a person is
but I love Texas more and I was giving
accessory you're not be about us answers
anymore
no honest as he is not know just tell me
what I want to hear because I like that
guy
forget honesty and that's it I'm pissed
off now that's gonna be on the Texas
blog and that was a great round right I
love Texas and that like I like Mack
Brown a whole lot I don't like that he
made me roommate with major Applewhite
my first three years in college and away
games that sucked and it ruined my
experience lie cuz like we're can
there's only one quarterback then can
play so it's just annoying to be in that
room with the guy that you know is
rooting against you when you're on the
field I never had any like really
awkward moments no I know we're hot I
just okay hon high five I'm good okay
he got me hot with that one yeah it was
the whole like did you're my dad my dad
even know I was there to no one oh come
on bro I mean seriously I was that's
what's so funny as your dad will watch
other people's kids games but he never
went to yours right your dad let's just
say this out phil was worried that
people were gonna think that he didn't
like that that people were gonna say
that but yet he stayed away and it still
got like it's exactly what i mean you
can't win that way oh yeah well that's
the hard thing about being a famous kid
now it's become a little bit more normal
right because there's more of that the
Mannings maybe like they both wants to
ball so many good you guys all that
stuff alright this one is from your me
I'll just ease now why is the aunt the
New England system always talked about
as being the most complex but the same
time people talk about them using the
same offensive concepts why is it so
complex or just have master Sims spit
out play calls for an hour and a half
maybe I've master Sims and end every
plague podcast with a play call in the
explanation that goes with it get that
[ __ ] in the podcast homie so why is it
so
Plex and I guess it's saying they talk
about them using the same offensive
concept yeah I don't know about that
part talk the same offensive concepts
their eye is it so completely it's so
intricate you know what what and just
I'm just gonna yeah I got you yeah so
it's cool all right so first of all it's
a complicated offense because of the
language of the offense right we're in
Kyle Shanahan's West Coast offense you
would call it double wing right in Bill
Belichick josh josh mcdaniels that
becomes zero flood slot or one flood
slot trips right in kyle Shanahan's
offense is in the in zero hole or one
hole in the in the new england offense
so it's a totally different language
from that standpoint is it a different
language so all the other coordinators
to it is really for the most part any of
their languages Mesha there's a few
people like Todd Haley probably matches
up with New England and all that I mean
non New England do other offenses kind
of sound like other offices they do yeah
so they all sound alike yes as in New
England has truly their own language
english language yes but like Kyle
Shanahan Sean Payton Sean McVeigh Jay
Gruden Jon Gruden Nathan Hackett you
just go down the floor Matloff or you go
down the list they have a lot of
similarity they don't call everything
exactly the same they're all from the
same tree but it's very simple would you
say it's because of this do you say it's
different because all of the other
coaches kind of come from trees right
whereas the Belichick tree is its own
thing it is its own thing and it's and
it's not necessarily its own thing
because he got it from Parcells and and
the guys Ron Earhart who's my dad's all
about McDaniels where did he get the
offense from them too he's fried he's
only been in New England he went from
Michigan State with Nick Saban to New
England Patriots it's the only two
places he'd been other than Denver stop
right in between and the Rams right in
the Rams exactly right after that so
that's where it's really complicated for
people as far as when they go there
because they're going like wait we use
numbers to say so it could be gun f
right 72 pearl smash wheel we're going
to
can it with 80 smack D fast and you're
like what okay well you know it just has
been a totally different word concept
because it's when I say 70 to 80 to
Pearl smash room for all means post and
a curl they can make so that's on the
right side and other people don't do
that know they know what other words
they would have a name or something else
forward or whatever what would be and in
like it would be Z in and the West Coast
offense a but go Xion and why you have
to know you have to run the post down
the middle like you'd have to know
certain things off of it or you'd have a
word now as far as the concepts being
the state of the actual action this is
like again this would be like what we
talked about last week on the pot Rogers
or like Kyle Shannon and how they make
things look the same through our guy
Warren sharp yeah how they make it look
the same who we talked about in the war
right his name is Warren Church but they
make it really good differences right
and the other thing I'll say this word
New England does New England sometimes
like where you think a receiver has an
option route right like Jon Gruden is
gonna teach that receiver you have a
real option here read the coverage if
the line is back to stop right whatever
New England's gonna tell you what your
option is they're gonna go no we've
noticed all week that this and we want
you to fake like you're gonna sit and
keep going and go that way or a Kris
hope right they are truly gonna make up
the option for you because they don't
even trust you to make decision they're
gonna go we've studied this all week and
we know which we want to do so that's
where they're different as well the
other thing that you've always said with
the New England they just do it
different they don't do seven step drops
they do six and a half yeah well they
yes they don't they don't believe in
drops at all are their wide receiver
routes different lengths to damn
definitely New England is more look deep
and then come short where I would tell
you a lot of other offenses are almost
the opposite they go look short and then
if that short guy's not there right away
then you can bring your eyes down the
field and the last thing I'll say about
New England to and where they're great
and where their tempo is great they have
so many all-purpose plays like Belichick
if we're sitting at the line of
scrimmage in New England when I was at
practices and they were sitting there
for the offense for 27 seconds and
Brady's like Chet Chet Chuck 24 check
he's like hurry up run the play
because you're just giving the defense
the more of the opportunity to sit there
and kind of like oh when they're in
these formations they only do these
certain things you're letting them
gather their thoughts that was in the
Warren Sharpe book to write he talked
about like your advantage is tempo yes
because defense needs to figure out they
have to go oh I've been studying all
week oh this formation and if you get it
off they get no really you get a chance
to think about it that's nothing he's
amazing so that situations like that
what more situations like that where
they'll call two plays but for the most
part they're so brilliant they've come
up with plays where they go Tom look to
the left the receiver on the left number
one the slot guy in the less number two
and then we're gonna have the receivers
all on your right side they're gonna be
coming into your vision across the field
so you can just read across the field
who cares what the coverage is just go
one to two to three to four and we like
these concepts against this team this
week and somebody will be open and
that's kind just remember that from the
Super Bowl it is suffocating when the
Patriots get tempo oh I know right it's
when you're up against it that's when
you realize that he's the maestro Yeah
right and it's the only other time I got
three maestro's that helped us was I
remember there was a Thursday night game
with Peyton in his prime and the Eagles
went to the RCA Dome back when that was
a thing and I've never seen the wheel's
beaten off the team like that was like
forty seven points and it's just they're
helpless and they're just running around
they're spinning and it's it's scary
no angle it's like one of those teams is
honestly like when your dad when they're
down by 10 you you're almost more scared
than when they're up by four just like
oh gosh here we go
yeah here comes the whole kitchen sink
all right let's go to an Instagram
comment this one is from Cody fro 24 and
it's directed to left Co and it says
left go what is your go-to biscuit and
where can I get one I would say that I
have oh I actually have two I have three
I have two in New York and one in LA
because I'm fat that fat my my favorite
spot that I go to all the time is this
place called cook shop I go there Lara
high-rez the manager he's the man I go
there pretty much like every Friday
morning and they have a biscuit and it's
just crunchy and soft in the middle and
they got a little Jam it's the best
another underrated spot there's a cool
dinner place called the Waverly Inn oh
yeah I've been there yeah a lot of fancy
it's cool it's like dimly lit in all
that stuff their roles for their dinner
or biscuits and there are these super
crunchy ones when you open it you feel
like you're cracking an egg but that's
how hard the outside is right and then
my favorite place I went to an LA is
this place called poppy and Rose and
their biscuits very similar to Waverly
Inn it's like that hard and it looks
like it's almost like developed and like
come off whereas the the cook shot ones
like a big hockey puck I don't know how
you do it in the morning I like a dinner
biscuit I'm not as fan of the my thing
is is I'll sit there and I'll get like a
cappuccino or like a nice hot liquid
yeah because then it kind of goes with
it yeah then you're just like it's not
even like noon and you're so fat you're
just I'm reading a paper and I'm eating
a biscuit and I'm like I will say this
this made me feel really good what is
there's a famous movie called dinner
with not Schmucks give me who's in it
it's a it's an older movie Breakfast at
Tiffany's
no but the Alan Alda dinner and all them
no dinner with I don't know but there
are Lux is the only thing that yeah all
I remember this was an actor one I'm not
gonna figure this out in this time I'm
just not gonna get us it's not gonna
happen okay horrible when your brain
doesn't work yeah it's not good but
this actor goes to cook shop like every
freaking day and he reads like books
about Abraham Lincoln and one day he was
sat down next to me and I looked over
and he had a biscuit and a coffee and
the waitress goes he gets that every day
and I go perfect
he does well and you don't even know I
forgot are you IRAs gonna guess not ben
stiller no because we saw him there when
we went the one time yeah oh we did yeah
all right and what do we call we thought
else oh they called them my they're like
hey don't say anything dude we're back
we are bad yes I've smoked a lot this
month it's this is the fake will Hoss so
it's will who's the best quarterback
Sims played against in college hmm
that's a good question
Kliff Kingsbury comes to my mind really
oh that man put up numbers Seneca
Wallace that Iowa State was very good
she's trying to give them my dinner with
Andre my dinner with uh and it's
actually Andre and I don't know who that
is and Andre get Gregor JP Lowe ceman I
played against too late yeah hmm she's
trying to think I didn't forget about
anybody else here I played the oldest
McCown there was another McCown not
Joshua Luke no there's another one
before that at Texas A&M I played my
first start ever against him in the
bonfire game but I think it's going to
be mmm Randy McKown no I can't it's
Randy this is Randy yes Randy the other
oh gosh you know I mean I did say like
you know Josh Heupel at Oklahoma who's a
player to beat him in the highest you
didn't win the but the other Jason White
did and he was a good player too but
them there is right it's a system I
think it's probably Seneca Wallace I
always think about it I'll never forget
MTV did like a true life I'm trying to
get drafted and they followed around
Seneca Wallace and I and that kid was
his highlights are incredible he was
incredible he liked when he had to play
like us or Oklahoma we were overmatched
them so he had horrible States in
Orleans right there was nothing to do we
had we
first round corners yeah his receivers
are gonna get open against our guys
because they like to the Bears
Nathan badger yeah sure rod Babers and
Quentin jammer and Cedric Griffin and
Mike I mean we had sweet jammer went to
Texas and jammer with the Texas best
corner name ever
Oh Jim was the man you didn't want to
mess with Jim know he was serious yes
serious Jam was one of those guys that
just looked at the weights and you know
whose highlights I tried to find when I
was at Louisville cuz in Louisville we
would cover Indiana football too and the
guy whose highlights I really wanted to
see who was the slot receiver for the
Steelers during one of those Super Bowl
runs not Antwaan Randle oh yeah the
Antoine Randall L played quarterback for
Indiana and I'll never forget when he
got drafted and Mel Kuiper's like I've
never seen quarterback highlights like
this and I can't find them anywhere but
Antwaan Randle ELLs college highlights
were amazing
down he got the gun yeah yeah this is
Noah Cruz his account is cr-z no.3 what
defensive adjustments will be made this
is a great question to combat our POS
also conduct Peterson's balls get any
bigger this year nope he's just gonna be
backs down yes it's amazing he was
supposed to be chip big balls Kelly but
ended up being Doug big balls Peters
it's unbelievable the fact that he let
Nick Foles come up to him say can we run
that play Philly Philly and Doug was
like yeah right like coaches don't say
yet of that let alone Nick Foles never
talk [ __ ] about Nick Foles I'm not
letting anybody talk [ __ ] and I'm
thankful
how will they combat the RPO is what do
you think what are you thinking well I
think the biggest thing is the teams
that do it on a very consistent basis
that you're gonna see DB's play
different techniques and certain down in
distance situations where they know the
RPO is right like so you're playing the
Eagles and like do what the Philadelphia
with the New England Patriots did on
schools all over those slanty exactly
play inside man and okay now we have
eight other guys that could play the run
but we got you guys playing man inside
to where they can't like okay fake the
run and our our weak side linebacker
flew in there so hard it's not the run
now there's this huge hole know our
corners there he's on the inside I think
you're gonna see that I think you're
gonna see when there's
more again a team that does it
consistently and a team feels like oh we
have that we have a bead on their
formations they'd like to do it on
that's where you're gonna see I think
guys switch assignments at times you
might see the linebacker take the
defensive ends assignment the defense
and drops back it's underneath it things
like that late rotational safety things
where they're gonna teach teams like
okay keeping your you know the weak side
safety we want you to come down just as
you see the ball being snapped right
every but we're gonna play zone and
we're just gonna learn how to stay in
our run gap but also be able to pass the
receivers off into our zone - the only
thing I'm hearing as you say all this as
Dan the Eagles are in these
[ __ ] heads because the RPO is
one of those things where you can still
hand it off yeah so if you fake the rush
and drop back we can run on yeah you
just have to hold that fake to the point
where you want them to pass I don't
think it's gonna be as a big factor as
everybody thinks in football this year
the RPO talked about I just don't
because I think it's it's too much of a
fad in the football world right now
whether it was you know the rumors I
heard of New England wanted to get Greg
Schiano on their staff because they were
worried about the RPI everybody this
offseason has taken three four weeks of
studying RPO and it doesn't [ __ ]
matter because we already got our ring
yeah got your ring still be a part of
your offense and I'm sure there'll be
some wrinkles off that so you think it's
gonna actually be stopped this year I do
I think it's it's the NFL moves quit
does it moves extremely quick and I mean
I can't remember a play in the Super
Bowl where the RPA Zach Kurt's touchdown
yeah you're right that was maybe one of
the slant to the left Dovan yeah but I
guess one of the only few completions I
can think of that they also scored on
the Corey Clemente bomb they scored on
the Alshon Jeffery bomb right but none
of those were our PA scored on Philly
Philly that's 28 right there but I'm
just saying that in our PL plays I'm
just saying I don't remember the RPO
play because I think New England had a
nice little formula of like what we said
that's really the thing when there's a
fat in the NFL yeah wait for that team
to face the Patriots they will expose
the weakness and then it will be so
everybody's all over it though I mean
after some sure nobody wants to use it
to you I talked to John Harbaugh at the
Superbowl because he was doing NBC
coverage with me so we talked
lotta ball I mean that that's what he
literally told me that's what their
staff was doing why he was at the Super
Bowl they were breaking down the RPO I
love which ways to stop it so that just
tells you that and I hope they were in
the RPO because Lamar Jackson would love
to run it
well the rise is gonna be the next thing
the RPL with the running quarterback
that's gonna be a different animal than
Nick Foles running the RPL cuz - Sean
Watson and Lamar Jackson like like not
even across balloons
Carson Wentz can do it for Biscay 'he's
got some wheels right mahomes has some
wheels one but is the Lamar Jackson
deshaun Watson that get me the most
exciting show because they're there
Kaepernick level of they could go 70
right you know I know
Carson Wentz ain't going seven now
Holmes can't go 72 risking an or 15 on
the best just great yes yes
but that will add another wrinkle for
those guys they might be able to live
with it
the RPO thing longer than the others
because you do have to worry about them
running yeah and you have to worry about
an extra run game fit and things like
that so this happened to me today I woke
up and I I was sitting there and I'm
kind of getting ready for the day and I
go I'm a Super Bowl champion and I don't
think I talked about it enough it's like
weird it's like this is the first
offseason where I've always wondered man
if I ever won a Super Bowl I would talk
about that [ __ ] all the time
and you feel like you've been soft on it
I feel like I haven't really gone that
ham like I feel like I should be wearing
like I have a friend I'm going to admit
something right now I have a friend in
California a cool fashion sneaker guy
different one you've never met him that
watches the Eagles game every night
before he goes to sleep the Super Bowl
and I'm going to admit this right now I
have not watched the game on television
yet I haven't either
I was there and there's part of me that
doesn't want to right there's part of me
that wants my time to be there and
that's it and then I thought well maybe
I'll do like a twitch or something where
me and Eagles fans can re-watch it and
I'm gonna experience I'm probably gonna
cry if I watch it but there's also part
of me that's like I don't know if I ever
want to watch it now watch it you can't
ever let that go man that's it's like
it's like but I feel like I should be
talking about it every day you're right
well you
we should have worn a few more Eagles
jerseys and hats into the office well I
go around to all the Eagles fans here
and I just shake their hands everybody
go your Super Bowl champion yes right
and they glow they're like all the [ __ ]
I am yeah because man like to all the
other fans out there like to the Detroit
fans and the Cincinnati fans and like
the Minnesota fans the team's I've never
won like holy [ __ ] like I bet you
they're sitting at me like man if we win
I'm gonna be obnoxious but hey it feels
good you've been classy Oh watch it back
I don't want to do it with Eagles fans
though like I would want to make it like
an event yeah okay no like rent a bar
throw it up on a big screen like watch
it by yourself I've watched one quarter
right and it was the when I was in the
airport after the game and I'm going
back to New York and I went into a bar
and it was on all the TVs because of
course it is and I got a glass of rose a
and an order of french fries and I
watched the third quarter and every time
something happened I'd like cheers and I
just live my best that's a great game Oh
God great all right
Cornelius underscore Fraley great
question would Nick Saban be a better
coach for Cleveland than Hugh Jackson
yes I do think so yes I think Nick Saban
if he thought his pro college yeah I
don't think Nick Saban would have that
hard of a time adjusting I think Nick
Saban really if he got into the NFL it'd
be a very similar story like a Pete
Carroll he'd come in you know after a
few years his team would be a Super Bowl
contender and it would go from there you
know again people got to remember to
Miami it wasn't horrible in Miami of a
solid seven but yeah it's got screwed
over because of what true Brees Dante
called exactly right they didn't pass
Drew Brees on the shoulder physical they
signed Dante Culpepper who had a bum
knee and I don't know how he got passed
for the physical but he did and that was
really because I almost got traded to
the Dolphins that next year what yeah
2006 when I wasn't healthy ended up on
Tennessee well 2006 is no yeah so this
is 2007 sorry
2007 you almost got traded a dolphin
dolphin play for next save I think
Parcells had taken over and press wanted
you yeah and Parcells wanted me and and
things like that and
you know what the hell happened I had to
give them the message through the back
channels that I couldn't do it don't
trade for me I'm not worth the damn the
trade for right now it's like you live
in Miami I know but that's the truth
it's like what I had to do to the
Baltimore Ravens that same year when I
went and worked out for them I don't
think I've ever told you this alright I
went out and work for the Baltimore
Ravens after you know Tampa held on to
me all of oh oh oh seven and then in 208
offseason and oh wait so they finally
released me and I'm gonna go work out
for the Baltimore Ravens Joe Flacco is a
rookie and they're going we're gonna
start drilling flat code week one and
they weren't they were uneasy about that
which I understand so I went there for a
workout and I wasn't normal and after
the workout got done with me and a few
other quarterbacks I told I believe it
was Eric decosta if I remember right I
was like don't don't say me I had to
tell him cuz I couldn't live with myself
to know that oh you're gonna you guys
really need me and you need to somebody
didn't depend on and I don't want to let
you people down I'm not I wasn't trying
to screw over anybody that way yeah I do
the same thing the very next day when I
went to Kansas City Kansas City offered
me so then why'd you even go these
workouts well because I was trying to
get on some rope and something like well
some sort of football team and they
would be situation right that could be
big so again the city was like we need
you to start in six days and I was like
damn I don't think I can throw the 15
yard comeback they offered me good money
like you know over a million and a half
dollars and I had a base loose their
quarterback at the time Brody Crowell
hole you Jeff Edwards you hurt probably
was better than verdict so it was yes
and it was just a really weird situation
to so then I had to tell them hey which
I had this was true I said I promised
Jeff Fisher and the Tennessee Titans
that I would not sign with you guys
until I worked out for them tomorrow and
that was the truth so I said Kansas City
I got to go to Tennessee tomorrow I
promised them like they've been made it
called me before anybody so I go to
Tennessee Tennessee didn't work me out
so that was their fault first of all
because they wouldn't have liked as much
what they saw because I was only like 70
to 80% Chris Sims but I knew in
Tennessee I didn't feel as bad about
screwing them over because
Vincent Kerry Collins were there I knew
I wasn't gonna mean you needed to depend
it on right away yeah because you're
also probably worried if you go to
Kansas City or Baltimore they put you on
the field and you put out bad tape [ __ ]
it's all forever no if I went to Kansas
City and they started me those first two
weeks my career would have been over
right there and instead you got like
three it's because I had to just play a
smart wait till I got healthy but yes
you're exactly right if I went to Kansas
City it would have been ducks and
interceptions and bad decisions because
my father like Oh Gruden was right right
and then I would have truly that
would've been my last year in the league
that was a good one all right good
speaking of which ask Sims about how he
feels his career would have gone if he
didn't get injured with the spleen so
that was perfect
IIIi don't know how we're gonna go on my
career was just starting you know oh
five we we we played well we go to the
playoffs
oh six we get off to the bad start and
then of course I got hurt I can only
speak to you know my potential you know
I did have talent I had a big-time arm I
was a good athlete and I was pretty
smart so you know do I think I could
have been something sure I certainly do
how good I never know but I know my
physical abilities and my work ethic
we're up there with just I think just
the fact that you have Baltimore in
Kansas City saying can you start for us
in six days shows what the rest of the
league thought well yeah I know
intending to work me out because we
don't need to work yeah because they
were so impressed with my three had
played them in pre seasons and I know
something about this GM that was in
Kansas City I forget his name right well
that was a person Carl Peterson yep it
was Carl Peterson who at that time and
then Baltimore its Ozzie Newsome yeah I
mean to respect a [ __ ] and Oz
Ozzie was just sitting up on the the the
top balcony watching the workout which I
admit something to you if I kind of
happy happy because you're here with me
if you were on an island I don't have a
name here unfortunately if you're on an
island your TV only played games of one
team in the NFL what team would you
choose to watch Josh note left go can't
pick the Eagles so I can only watch one
you're gonna pick the Niners no I don't
think I'm gonna pick the Patriots I
think I am gonna pick the Patriots feel
like if you're watching the page
you got a pretty good clue let's go
probably watching the game of the week
every week right then you're going oh
we're watching the team that's certainly
towards the top of the league and the
most dangerous and if I watch
Jacksonville I'm just gonna be cursing
out I want to say you know really going
but I know my team is I think I was
still going to England Hill I'm picking
the team that I called the NFL League
Pass team last year where every game you
got to watch it's the Chargers Phillip
Rivers gonna make it fun that defense is
attacking they take shots there they
always play fun games you're League Pass
team this year I don't know yet there's
so many young quarterback Chiefs in like
the Bears I can't access their keys and
the Bears the Texans are all like could
be a lot of fun to be a lot of could be
a lot of fun
alright let me flip this bad boy over
this is from Malcolm G Reds underscore
Santana who's the scariest offensive
player Sims ever went against and I
think you're gonna say and read but or
it might be the two defensive tackles
from Jacksonville so many they're all
scary but I feel like Edie Reed you tell
the story of him in the back and read
lurking scared my brain more than
anybody else oh you have Ray Lewis there
to be scared everything about me that
day ray I got scared of this is the 2006
opener we in Tampa think we're gonna
we're gonna wear our All Whites so
Baltimore has to wear all in the hotel
there you go [ __ ] you Tampa and we're
all black they're like screw you okay
and I could say this we're sitting in
the huddle and I'm nervous I mean I'm
nervous before every game I mean early
on my crab would throw up before games
every now and then but this mom's
sphaghetti yeah yes exactly so this is
Baltimore Ravens 2006 and it's they're
big and bad and Steve McNair is on their
team and they think they're going to the
Super Bowl so yeah they were the number
one seed yeah and so but Ray Lewis
during the TV timeout is over the ball
dancing like it's football time and he's
doing a little shimmy with it right over
the ball and I just remember thinking
like damn this guy is like such the man
that he has absolutely no fear of
anybody out here on this football it's
gotta be cool to feel like that I mean
it's got a
unbelievable so I would say he is
certainly up there well scared you
I mean Julius Peppers I've told you like
every time I took the snap and we played
Carolina Panthers I was gonna look over
my right shoulder to see what kind of
jump Julius Peppers got because Julius
Peppers if I saw the jump and I thought
oh he got off really good your left well
I was gonna take a peak at least when I
got to step four again to go let me just
see where he is and that corner wise any
corners that you were afraid to throw at
yeah I just got to think of who they are
I mean hmm which ones that I was really
scared DeAngelo Hall had my number he
definitely did a few times oh my gosh
three or four times it's just like any
Thai feel like any time the ball one in
the up in the air it's somehow found to
his way no I can't say that a lot that I
I didn't have another extensive time to
say they were I was scared of safety
defensive tackle big defensive tackles
were like Chris Jenkins on some of those
Carolina Panthers football he was a
monster one that helped bust your spleen
he did and he was one of those guys
where those guys are so big when you
walk up to the line of scrimmage and you
walk up and you go okay me and my Center
are walking up together and this big
mother effort sitting there waiting for
us and he lines up right over you and I
got my sweaty hand in the sweaty ass
there's like a foot away for not even a
foot it's inches from his from now our
sinners head right and you're like so
this this stumpy [ __ ] has to
snap the ball and get in his way and
save my life I used to be like I don't
know how he's gonna do this can he
really snap me the ball and stop at the
same time I used to really been how they
do away they're just that quick they are
that quick like Patrick they example
right it's unreal you talked about Sean
Taylor a lot of people send us the clip
in the playoff game where Sean Taylor
picks up the fumble and returns it and
you're like all over the place one
definitely thought the guy was down
there like how could you be in the pile
that long and and I'd still be dad was
telling you I know he was down yeah I
get to say that the perfect view yeah
but it was one of those things on replay
it was such a mosh in there they
couldn't tell
but like dude if it's gonna take you
that long and then you and I think
anytime someone gets up like this you
were down on your knee but we got
screwed over in that game by sometimes
but that - yeah I look like a big puss
cuz people go oh you didn't recover the
fumble I kind of got stuck in between
that's just the honest thing ran forward
about the time you were running forward
then I was running forward I could see
the ball loose and maybe if I just went
like I'm gonna dive for it and go get it
maybe I would have but I also saw him
about to pick it up so I was like oh
[ __ ] like do I go for the ball or he's
gonna pick this up and run for a
touchdown and I kind of got stuck in
between and nothing you know I did ended
up doing nothing Sean Taylor rumbling
bubble and stuff was amazing to somebody
else I was probably scared of but I
can't think of who it is this is from CJ
holding the L better in 2018 miles
Garrett or Khalil Mack hmm and I guess
better from a football perspective
better from a statistical perspective
all of that stuff that's a really good
one I'm a big miles Garrett believer and
I think of miles Garrett stays healthy
that he will have a better year that
coilmac and that's really saying a lot
cuz you know we both know how awesome he
is and Cleo Mack forget the sacks people
don't realize he's truly one of the best
run stopping defense ends in football
but I don't think miles Garrett's at his
level yet yeah
but in terms of the season I would all
say Cleveland has a much better defense
than the radar exactly right much better
defense other people you got to worry
about in that defensive line I would say
a more creative scheme and Greg Williams
to that might find ways to just free him
up to get a few more cheap ones at a
Khalil Mack which is gonna be the
Cincinnati system which is you know for
two it's kind of a cover three press
Bale type of scheme and yeah it's a
little more predictable that way
Garrett's big-time I'm excited for him
yeah really am all right - left Matt s
T's 14
how can people call Mike Tomlin a top
five coach but his team's never get over
the hump they did win a Super Bowl and
they went to another one they went to so
he's bended - which one do they lose
they lost the Green Bay and the Aaron
Rodgers one marriage-like and they are
the number one defense in the NFL
yeah and
really the big pie that game was uh who
was that fast wooly Parker had a big
fumble in that game I don't think it was
really wasn't Parker he was the first he
was the guy with the French name oh it
was wasn't Rashad Mendenhall I think it
was but regardless hey I understand the
concerns about like Mike Tomlin and all
that it's not always done perfect it was
Mendenhall right that was a but that was
a huge moment in that game I Pittsburgh
was on their way to winning that game at
least the motors had all the momentum
herbal towels were out in full force it
was the biggest mistake I'm trying to
figure out what had happened in the game
had the ball nearly seven minute I don't
know they were overcoming a deficit I'm
trying to find it but yeah keep going
you're talking about Mike Tomlin yeah I
mean I know Mike Tom I do I have great
respect for Mike Tomlin okay so that's I
mean the first thing is is my answer is
probably gonna be a little bit biased
but I try not to be biased in my answers
like this and I understand what kind of
football coach he is it was 21 17
started the fourth quarter may have the
Steelers had been down twenty one two
three right they may get 21 17 second
and two at the 33 so they're in field
goal range and he fumbles that's right
that's right they kind of taken over the
glade a point so I know they haven't got
over the hump
okay certainly I get that like to the
degree the last few years it hasn't been
great but again let's just keep things a
little bit in perspective
can I read off his career achievements
here yeah please I mean 2007 first in
the AFC North eight first in the AFC
North okay third and AFC North first in
the AFC North second in the AFC North
third in the SE nor second in the AFC
North first and they have seen North
second in the AFC North first in the AFC
North first in the AFC North I mean it's
ten and 612 and Ford 9 and 7 12 and 4 12
and 4 ok to 8 and 8 seasons and 12 and
13 and then not a losing season out a
losing season and then 11 of 5 10 and 6
11 and 5 and 13 and 3 so he's never had
a losing season no he's a hundred and
sixteen and sixteen his career with a
six sixty six point six sixty five point
nine winning percentage I used to be
someone that would call Tomlin Allah
and then you just kind of realize that
like his whole mantra is let the guys
play it is and he gets the most energy
out of them and I think the thing about
the Steelers is you always have the
certain names right you have the bed and
you have the Antonio Brown but the depth
of some of those teams have not been
good over the years because so much
money was going to certain guys and
they've been playing in the toughest
division one of the toughest divisions
in the sport that's the most physical
Cincinnati was to it over that RIM right
belt Baltimore was really good over that
realm now granted you all had Cleveland
but I think the thing is - he didn't
have a lot of pieces defensively for a
long time wearing his talented on
defense as their secondary was very
underwhelming for a while they had no
corners you know they lose to the
Broncos and the Broncos remember the Tim
Tebow game you know people forget
remember Ben Roethlisberger how bad his
ankle was at the end of that year so
that hurt their chances that year but I
mean okay they lost a Baltimore in the
AFC wild card game in 14 didn't have
Polamalu he had pell-mell towards the
end of his career yes well yeah you're
right he well he had Polamalu prime
years to a little bit of both but yes
he's also in the counties how to deal
with the Baltimore Ravens the New
England Patriots and really I think he
gets a downgrade in his name Mike Tomlin
because everybody like looks at New
England and Bill Belichick and they just
go well they keep winning and they do it
what's wrong with Tom one in Pittsburgh
why can't they they're like if him
they're Harbaugh can't win in the AFC
everyone else is like ah the AFC we give
up then Belichick wins it's like they're
the only two guys that even try to stand
up to new it's like being a tennis
player in the Federer and it's not easy
right or it's like yes I'ma be in the
New York Knicks and playing the Chicago
Bulls in Jordan era see yeah being any
Eastern Conference Player in the LeBron
tough so again I know it's not always
perfect situational football could use
some help at times but it's a lot easier
if it has never lost that team know he
is that and he's one of the greatest
motivators I've ever been around
in what way well give me a time in which
he felt really motivated by my time he
is just there a story that comes to mind
or a moment he has tremendous energy
about him do you remember any speeches I
mean oh he was fourth-quarter gangster
coach for us what does that mean for
Gruden like
four quarters of the season would
appoint a coach to be like hey Rod
Marinelli you're gonna motivate the two
through eight you're there you're the
guy that's gonna go up when we have a
team meeting and give a little
five-minute speech on what we need to do
this week and Tomlin was always the
fourth comma toppled was fourth quarter
gangster walk in with a boombox on his
shoulder have a t-shirt that says fourth
quarter gangster cuz this is when we got
to be some gangsters and close out the
season and go to the playoffs and do all
that and he would you hear how he talks
he's got every great phrase in the world
in his brain he's an unbelievable
communicator his energy is what you
would think could be every day he's
never faced never like never and he is
not afraid to call people out when
they're bad and he does it the right way
to where he doesn't like demoralize you
in front of the team how does he do it
he could just he's gonna probably show
some good that you've done and be like
this is the guy you are not this guy
what is this what do we do it and each
might show some clips from practice
never see him step to a Warren Sapp no
he wouldn't do a barber know he had like
Ronde Barber and them had such great
respect loves able to eaten out of his
hand like if he hears some bird seeds
weren't even like great that's great so
he was almost one of those guys that
when he got into the front of the room
people got excited just to hear him talk
about God and I'll just I'll add this to
sense to it like I think he heard me
criticize him a little during the season
last year in the New England game and so
we were was the reason we were at the
end of the New England game they botched
it during the replay right they should
have had someplace to go the whole
situation fakes bike interception they
lose the game
I thinks I feel like so I see him with
owners meetings and he had some words
for me to say but he said it in the
right way this is where I love him cuz I
think he was basically letting me know
like hey jerk-off I heard you
criticizing me during the year but he
was like basically hey would you wanna
when you want to get for real and come
and coach and get real again and get
into the tough stuff and just not talk
about it
you caught me I'll get you a spot on my
staff that's what he said he was
basically letting me know like hey I
heard you talk [ __ ] about my game it's
okay
and her name is easier to look so [ __ ]
you and that's what I love about my she
doesn't do media like he only doesn't
talk to media like he does in this press
conference you know what I read about in
those really cool was like he's such a
believer in like father figures and
stuff and he's just all about like if
you need to go be with your kids or
whatever like that's that's his thing
man like he was to everyone to be a dad
yes would you go and get a child but the
Pittsburgh Steelers staff I mean he'd be
one of those coaches I'd love to go work
that staff in general I think is awesome
because of him and Mike Munchak and of
course I used to really I like Todd
Haley when he was there yeah
yeah I mean that would be one of the
places that if you're coaching is done
though I guess it is but if you like
those that would be one of my five top
jobs though like Oh Pittsburgh Steelers
Mike Tomlin I'm down would you coach for
Jon Gruden yes really
yeah definitely yes I can't believe
you're just a masochist is like a
stepchild alright last one this is from
mr. tang easy breh mr. Sangay what is
sims's go to munchies when he hits the
back porch and then he tweeted later I
don't want left gonna feel outside like
his munchies - so what would you say
your top Munchie is when you hit the
back porch yeah all right
yours is gonna be weird it depends on
the night I like lentil soup no it's
definitely I think if I'm going like
might I get a good barbeque chip really
could be like right salty mood like I
need a little salt in my life I will say
this if a barbecue chip is well coated
oh that's what I mean I have a certain
ones that I like you get that perfect
cool ranch Dorito that's another one
those are like so chips like the
all-natural Doritos they have now
there's some all-natural barbecue chips
out there like that could I can go
through a bag maybe two and a night
after that it's gonna go to probably
haagen-dazs chocolate or some type of
mint chocolate chip ice cream
yeah just like like one of the smaller
ones the pints of a pint has no chance
against me that's done in minutes I am
gonna carve around that yeah
you know you don't do it lately you go
ham yes I do if I do yeah
that's why I might had a gut in some of
those social medias last we have too
much time I would say my my big one is
popcorn like I love popcorn you a salt
and butter guy - yeah I do olive oil on
the popcorn no it's really good I like
it much
I also like a really good piece of pizza
like I'm not gonna be up against that
and then all right I do too
yeah and then I'm not gonna lie like if
you give me like a pad thai or a Robin
yeah I enjoy a nice little ramen okay I
know you would never he knows I mean I
would that's yeah that's a little more
that's like that's not much right though
yeah there's like a Jersey New York
Pizza this area there is there some
nights where I go honey don't make
dinner than that I'm gonna eat up pie
like I'm going on when you epc eat the
whole pie I can usually the whole pie
yeah and so on it's the eight pieces for
sure that my problem is like i black out
from piece three to piece five like
those are just I didn't even realize I
ate oh those are yeah you're right
there's nothing when it really gets into
this sort of like I'm gonna savor this
one that's six when I go that's good I
can shove two more down in there so then
when you do that mr. like dietitian
nutritionist no I'm not perfect do you
just go like really hard the next day
like do you not eat breakfast like no I
eat but I might like limited a little I
try them the next day any day I just
listen to my body and I try not to
overeat for the most part but yeah I
would be more conscious of my workout
and and maybe what I eat during the day
know yeah like Friday night date night I
was almost starved myself all day
because you know you're gonna go ahead I
know is still like an NFL player with
cheat days and cheat I'm gonna smoke a
big fatty and we're gonna get on the
train or go somewhere somewhere nice and
I am going to order 80 dishes I'm gonna
eat so much for like the waiters usually
laugh at me at dinner because they look
at me in there like there's no way
you're gonna be able I'm like I trust me
I'm gonna be able to do it I worked out
really hard and I barely had breakfast
or lunch today I'm written what is
usually tell them I smoked weed I'm like
I had the munchies and your wife at this
point it's just like that's what he did
that's right does she eat a lot two of
those dinner she's a phenomenal eater
she is
she's not a smoker by any stretch of the
Matt he just straight Sicilian yeah just
loves food my girlfriend has this thing
where she eats and then she doesn't eat
for forty minutes but then she eats
again I heard you say that I've never
seen I've never seen anything like it my
life goes back for around two dude I've
seen her pass out on the couch and wake
up and just start finish her meal and
I'm like how can you do that right I'm
like I eat in one sitting and then I'm
done yeah all right now you're learning
more about us people of Earth guys thank
you so much for all the great questions
again if we didn't get to them I am
going to answer some on Instagram
stories so I'll put up that little box
that says ask me anything and you guys
can send it if there's four Sims
I'll Texans and get the answers yeah for
the Jackson Hall going to Wyoming don't
go to Wyoming I'm going to Anguilla yeah
I'm gonna do nothing yeah that's what
you are gonna do we're gonna get ready
there's something to do there no we're
gonna get ready and then we're back in a
brand new studio the week of the 23rd
and then after that it's all systems go
we're gonna be trying to go to some
training camps getting ready for the
season it should be great follow us at
Sims in love go we appreciate you so
much for Sims peace out homies vendrick
the teacher would say good evening and
the lef koe man says holla holla holla
holla holla holla holla
we will holla at you guys later enjoy
your week sorry only getting one episode
hope it was a good one talk to you guys
soon